yeah it was it was interesting i
what shocked me the most was how like
transparent it all was like the hosts
were like very
transparent with about that like they
were like we don't care but but they
they do this whole act that they do care
yeah but it's so obvious that they don't
and and they they almost tell them that
they don't care in many ways it's really
part of the customers yeah it's really
strange and um that's that's where we go
into the whole psychology of it and then
the tactics they employ to actually you
know garner these
it's something i don't think i can quite
it's
if you're not from japan it would take
years for you to wrap your head around
because you have to feel like you need
to understand
what led up to this as a culture
yeah yeah yeah
so so like as a host what is the big
appeal of host clubs you know
from from the other side yeah why do so
many girls in japan love going to host
clubs and like not just going but like
spending like
gangsters
yeah these hoes very good question so
this has kind of a lot of sides to it
but um the main you know answer i would
say is just the
social structure of japan itself right
as you also mentioned
japan is not really like
a social friendly place
especially
when you look at the type of people that
actually go to the host clubs
so again a huge tangent but the reason
why i wanted to go to host club or one
of the reasons is to see what kind of
people actually work there yeah what
kind of people actually go there because
it made no sense like why would i spend
money to chat with guys yeah i can just
go to you know bar and pay to drink with
a guy right that's a girl yeah so
um once i entered that was like the main
thing that i looked into what kind of
people go there why do they go there and
what kind of people actually work there
so what i figured out is
most of the customers that we would get
and i'm sure it's the same across the
board
they're also people who work in the
nightlife
yeah
like easy i would say more than eighty
percent of the people that we got they
were always you know like
whatever some kind of a nightlife where
your pride your dignity it's [ __ ]
stepped on all day long and it's
you know you're out of your job the one
thing you want is being pampered one
thing you want is feeling like you're
being respected one thing even if it's
artificial as [ __ ] yeah you know it you
want to feel this guy giving you this
utter
you know sense of service and then you
know
do anything for you kind of thing yeah
yeah yeah quite a depressing aspect of
japanese culture yeah if you put it in
that perspective yeah but it has its own
culture within itself where you know
once you go a lot to a host club for
example like you get to meet the chacho
yeah you know like all like owners
basically
clubs and they're not like you know
random ass people they're usually very
wealthy japanese businessman yeah and if
you're in the nightlife and then you get
to hang out with the chacho you know he
might elevate you in some way or other
maybe he might put you in a different
you know like a kabakra or something you
know so there's actually different of
the reasons as to why you would go to
the host club depends on the person all
right so how often would you get like
you know like a newbie come to the host
club like you know someone who's first
time ever yeah you know someone who's
like saying not part of like the
industry or that kind of environment
someone just like someone is just like
curious to be like oh i want to see what
a host club is yeah
actually when you start off that's your
main goal um you go outside the club you
go nampa on the street with random girls
and you let them know what's number one
yeah you just hit on them
bro you're like a 2010 youtuber
camera's right there just kidding
so you know the thing was you just go up
to them be like hey i work right there
you know i would love to drink with you
it's a thousand six hundred yen per hour
on my whole day
right what are the what like what's the
success rate okay
one in a hundred will be generous yeah
right
so oh well they'll do it just because
they feel sorry for you
bro it's japan bro people value their
time and money yeah yeah actually i'm
privacy
exactly exactly no one appreciates some
random dude getting this close and being
like
you know no one's gonna be like yeah
let's do it you know yeah because i see
it all the time when you go to like
shibuya and shinjuku of like these dudes
who clearly work at host clubs yeah
these girls and these girls just don't
even don't even give them like any
attention they're used to it bro
japanese girls that go to these places
they know that some catchy guy is going
to come to you yeah just you know walk
straight ahead yeah yeah it's kind of
the same with like you know maid cafes
but just like up the opposite way around
yeah you said like you go to akihabara
or you know
kabukicho and you like see a lot of
maids on the streets trying to get
people to come in their maid cafes as
well you just like don't even give them
periphery at all just like
just like don't make eye contact don't
make it like the moment they realize in
the periphery they are there they'll
just come off like give you a pamphlet
right yeah
sucks
so like so was that what you had to do
as you when you joined the host club was
that like your first jobs uh yeah
initially that was my first ever proper
job after the you know pizza bar but
yeah
so for the first you know a couple of
months
well not even the first year because you
know i wasn't living in japan
so for the first time i was there in
that second year that i was there
you go in at 5 00 p.m
clean the [ __ ] place with your other
homies that are not
selling right
yeah so you just make everything
pristine as [ __ ] and then your senpais
would come in and be like what's the
[ __ ] dirt there bro
you know
that thing but i love that about you
fanny i mean but you know it's fun
because i still make banter out of it
you know yeah like no one would go up to
their senpai and be like how about you
do it [ __ ] but like i would do it you
know like
his stuff and be like you know number
one you think you're this hot [ __ ] [ __ ]
come you clean it i'm not doing it [ __ ]
you and he'll be like yo i like you
yeah the samples are old
like that's the whole they're like oh
something cause i'm fighting them right
has just got so much material yeah
absolutely and it's the same with the
way you approach the customers because
um the number one rule they tell you
when you join is do not ask them
personal questions don't ask them what
they do your their real name their
address you know how they make their
living it's so hard because i remember
when i did it i was like [ __ ] this like
when you meet someone all you do is like
just ask them like hey yeah yeah yeah
he's like how do i i don't know
and combined with the fact that i'm also
you know used to that but also my main
purpose was to do a survey as to you
know why the [ __ ] do people come to
these places anyway yeah so you know i
was like crack okay first girl i ever go
into you know
what why why are you here why are you
here yeah right here
and my senpai's are just like what the
[ __ ] what the girls like well that's
what worked in my favor because i was
acting like i was your girlfriend yeah
exactly that's like the girl's like no
one's no one's ever asked me this is a
[ __ ] anime plot
i was acting that japanese
transformation
the social experiment guy
what's up guys
well the main purpose also
was to get information but again
i was playing this character where i'm
that gaijin guy who has no idea what the
[ __ ] he's doing but you know it's that
friendly neighborhood gaijin doing his
best right that character gathering so
was that like a character you like made
up or was that something you were just
like okay i i know this is the character
i'm going to play and i'm going to play
actually really because i never gave a
[ __ ] what they told me to do
because i was like bro you fire me today
i'll go to the next place you know
they pay me money to go to the
interviews like i give a care you know
right right
so you know you figured out the system
man yeah the system oh it's just all
about not giving a [ __ ] host club hate
this one trick
to find out
so you know employing this tactic of
just asking these girls like what do you
do
my main structure of conversation was
literally just being a life coach to
these girls
um but
just bitcoin nft
invest
just to go over like general structure
so i think last time i went over you
know how i got chosen and [ __ ]
so you know you clean the stuff you
start sitting down with girls and then
when there's a new girl that comes in
who's never been to that club before
what you do is each guy gets to sit down
with her for five minutes yeah just five
minutes in my video you give your card
you compliment them you talk them
and then after five minutes they switch
around i i love that host clubs have
business cards hosts have business cards
yeah sure i brought mine today bro it's
really sick it's like some stock trading
stuff let me
sorry
so like so you had five minutes to prove
yourself yeah exactly so you do that you
rotate and after the first 45 or 50
minutes you choose someone right yeah
how'd you stand out in five minutes yeah
well see that's the thing bro most
people just you know go like oh your
eyes are beautiful
i love your nails and stuff like that
john comes in why are you here
i'm like why are you here why don't you
go somewhere else
hang out with your friends and she's
like what do you mean
and i'm like oh my god i love him
well you're spending money to drink with
me that means you know there's a reason
why you're here why are you here
and then like i make them explain like
justify their their reason for being
there right so like i clearly don't get
along with close-minded people or people
who are not willing to chat bro you
would get ladies that would just come in
and open their phones and just you know
scroll through and i see that for like a
minute and i'm like yeah no
[ __ ] change all right i'm not gonna
sit with you i mean to be fair that is a
that is a waste of money like but it's
what's in my head it's a waste of the
hosting a lot of the host clubs they
offer uh unlimited drinks yeah exactly
for the first 60 minutes you're in there
yeah yeah um and and it's normally
considerably cheaper yeah it's [ __ ]
cheap it's like it's like one thousand
yen for like all you can drink yeah so i
guess i guess ghost has come into just
yeah because the next drink if you buy
one beer it's like it's like 30 bucks
yeah it's everything's like 10 times the
[ __ ]
market price yeah i mean it's like that
with a lot of like even girls bars as
well that's how you they get you in
right they get you in for the all you
can drink and then
and then they sell you on other stuff
right yeah yeah yeah luckily i think
guys are a bit easier to convince to
stay in the bar than uh